The African Union becomes a permanent member of G20.
This monumental geopolitical news was announced today
by Indian Prime Minister Nahendar Moody.
The current members of the G20 are European Union,
Argentina, Australia,
Brazil, France,
India, Indonesia,
Italy, Japan,
Canada, China,
Mexico, Russia,
Saudi Arabia,
Great Britain,
South Africa,
South Korea,
Turkey, Germany
and the United States of America.
The African Union,
consisting of more than 50 African nations,
will be the 21st member.
African Union has more than 1 billion
people living in it,
controlling a GDP of around $3 trillion.
That is approximately the same size as India.
What are my thoughts on this?
I have a lot to say on this topic.
First of all,
I formally want to thank
President Mahandar Moody of India.
Also want to thank Russia and China
who has been pushing for a EU membership in the G20
for a while.
Africa is on the rise,
there is no denying about that.
No serious Geo politician will deny that.
Africa is coming up very,
very quickly.
This is very good for Africa collectively
because individual African nations
are not that strong economically
to have geopolitical leverage.
But a united 50 African states,
$3 trillion will have power geopolitically so.
African unities
not about identity politics,
who the black man chooses to marry
or what religion African people have
or political affiliation.
African unities
about strategic economic cooperation and partnership
to push for agendas that benefit the whole continent.